[Music]
you know people say bring your authentic
self to work and it pisses me off when
companies do that because i'm like [ __ ]
you you know you're not letting people
do that you're not making it safe
because you've got this rule that rule
this quota
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
vayner nation how are you uh it is me
gary vaynerchuk thank you so much for
joining the audio experience i uh have
the great pleasure of having a guest on
today that i am
incredibly fond of uh normally
i would say probably 80 percent of the
time the guests that have come through
here over the last three years have been
people i don't really know just a little
bit from maybe a little interaction here
and there on dm
but never a meal never like lots of time
it's just uh it's infrequent that i i
use the platform for people that i have
more context for and so i'm really
excited today uh robert hansen has
become a friend
uh
but most of all and the reason i wanted
to have him on the podcast and i asked
him to be on the podcast is
i'm spending a lot of time around
leadership as a lot of you know i
haven't really announced this as some of
you my discord if you're following me
friends know i do have a new book coming
out in november
i'll give it a big promotion soon so i'm
not going to say any more here but it
made me really tap into emotional
intelligence from a leadership
standpoint it's been always very clear
to me i've always put it out in my
content but the truth is i haven't been
close enough to enough executives
to really
feel like i'm willing to co-sign
somebody i have intuitions if somebody
said who's a good leader i throw out
names because i have intuitions
but i really believe that this gentleman
is a great leader and i think he relies
on a lot of the things that i rely on
and i think it's important to to have my
audience hear it in a different way from
a different perspective with different
nuances because it's never going to
exactly be the same so robert with that
incredibly big co-side why don't you
take the floor for three minutes and
tell everybody who you are what you're
currently doing maybe a little bit about
yourself
and then i've got some questions for you
with very specific agenda around some uh
stuff that i want the audience to hear
sure i'm happy to do it hey uh gary hey
everybody uh and gary i appreciate that
uh kind introduction um i uh i'm
currently running the wine and spirits
business at uh constellation brands i've
been in business my whole career uh i'll
i'll frame that up relative to the
conversation you want to have gary by
saying
i never really thought i would choose a
business and career a career in business
but what i realized is
i think business has an opportunity to
not only be
a source of economic opportunity but a
force for positive change so
i've you know i i was trained well early
in my days i was at levi's for quite
some time and then i became a public
company ceo i ran a private
equity-backed uh uh jewelry business
where i met get you know you gary
the first time around and we've
developed a relationship i think uh you
know recently obviously we um we
partnered as uh constellation brands
acquired your empathy brand and we've
been leveraging that to great success
across our portfolio but you know i
think fundamentally this is really about
you know the the sort of why behind
success and uh just as a lead into the
conversation you know i never expected
to be here uh you know i i i feel super
blessed to have achieved uh the impact
that i've had in business uh and i often
you know am asked why and i think it's
the combination of aligning your
passions to a higher purpose in business
and coming back to the point i made
earlier i do think business can be a
source of economic opportunity but can
only be sustainably that if uh your
business the business you're homing is a
force for positive change and that comes
down to
uh
you know driving a culture of values
based high performance and that's really
what my brand is about i'm a builder at
heart i've never worked in you know big
companies where you're trading a
sharepoint here or there um you know
with competitors it's really like you
like the process of building it up i
love the process of taking things and
transforming them or taking new things
and building them up but doing so from a
values-based high-performance cultural
perspective that's me
that so that was your per well actually
here's a fun question middle school or
high school what did you think you were
going to do
don't take me that far back
even before college do you have us do
you recall did you have a sense did you
have
i certainly didn't i made a very
conscious choice not to pursue this and
don't hold me accountable in karaoke at
some point in the future but i was uh i
was training to be a uh a professional
opera singer uh
when i was in middle school in high
school and then i just i chose life over
that craft because it would have
required dedicating my life when did you
when did you do that
uh i was i was doing it all the way
through i was competitive swimmer and
also i was studying um you know classic
music and opera
and i made the choice not to really
pursue either career as i went into
college so i would say in my
junior to
senior year of high school i just said
i've got to choose life i have a big
curiosity and a high ambition to get
exposed to as much as i can how did that
land with coaches parents other
relatives friends like if you were doing
those knowing a little bit about both of
those things just a little bit
those are big commitments you've been
probably doing them for a long time
did who struggled with that decision the
most that was close to you you know
everybody honestly with the exception of
my mom
um that's awesome my mom was like you
know it's your life man you gotta you
gotta grab it and and and live it the
way you wanna live it uh i'll always
love and respect you but you're yeah
you've gotta walk in your own shoes
every single day and if you can't do
that authentically then you know you're
not gonna be a happy person so i
everybody from coaches to you know my my
opera coach to uh you know the rest of
my extended family i had a uncle that
tried to chop me off at my knees for not
pursuing
you know my my athletic career so it but
but it all worked out in the end i feel
super blessed
speaking of working on the end and you
said you were trained well levi's
you know i always think giving flowers
is a nice thing especially if the person
is alive um are you
do you have a sense of which leader
really
impacted you
in your professional career that you
were like oh she or he
i like that i like the way they're doing
that i want to emulate that or maybe
they were
maybe cancerous to you or who knows what
does anybody stand out in that first
five to seven years
sir certainly and look i don't want to
belabor this point but i would have to
recognize a series of people my first i
would say true professional coach was my
original boss that levi's a woman named
julie pally
and the division president that hired me
a guy by the name of tom fano both who
are around and then uh you know
subsequent ceos that were running the
company john anderson
phil marino
as two examples because
they
really instilled in me this concept of i
think
driving my career sort of horizontally
to have vertical ascension and that
meant really just getting a lot of
skills and experience working
domestically working abroad taking on
different challenges but they also as
leaders instilled in me this concept of
value space high performance i had one
uh early on mentor uh
who ran the international division and i
was thinking about moving into the
public
sector and he's like don't do that
you're a rare uh
you you approach business in a rare way
and i think if you can really develop
your career in business you could have a
bigger impact than a lot of
non-government organizations or even
governmental organizations on culture
and on the development of society so it
was really interesting earning learnings
early in my career and then i had
incredible mentors you know mindy
grossman's one that comes to mind uh at
ww she's been a great mentor and coach
over time and i was exchanging with
someone yesterday about ursula byrne she
was the ceo at xerox at the time and she
took a cold call from me and just said
she wanted to be of help so you know
long story short i tell people all the
time people want to help make the call
and people generally have a good heart
and good values and they want to be able
to help and i took advantage of that and
feel super lucky to have had people like
that in my life
what um
what do you think about
uh
you know it's this is something i really
admire in the way i watch you know
obviously you are now
managing
uh at a higher level but you there's
everybody falls underneath you but you
know john and nate my partners at
empathy i mean these are two kids i took
out of college and they worked every day
of their life with me actually john left
and worked at a wine distributor for a
year but like
90 percent of john's career and 100 of
nate's career were under my cocoon and
they were close to me the whole time and
you know to think that they could get as
fortunate as they did to land into your
world where
you know i think my the greatest thing i
do when i do it well is eliminate fear
and
it has become so obvious to me in my
interactions of watching you interact
with others and then obviously i have
such a front row seat because i'm still
very much big brother to those two and
so i get even more details in this 18
months two years whatever it's been now
um you know probably more than you want
no no
honestly i mean this authentic you know
this is what's fun about my audience
like they know like i don't give a [ __ ]
about anything other than like myself in
the scheme of like i'll never say
something i don't believe in and so
you know
why do you think you do a good job
eliminating fear do you think you do a
good job eliminating fear
and how much does that impact people
being able to actually bring you know
people say bring your authentic self to
work and it pisses me off when companies
do that because i'm like [ __ ] you
you know you're not letting people do
that you're not making it safe because
you got this rule that rule this quota
and i think you know
i think you're doing that and i like
that and i think it's interesting and
i'm
curious what your perception is to what
i just said
yeah sure i mean look there's a lot to
unpack there maybe i'll i'll say three
things please um one and i'll and i'll
challenge a point that that you just
made and others have made it to me as
well i just happen to believe it you
know intrinsically i do think you have
to bring your authentic self to work in
order to have the kind of impact that
you want to have because i would say
what i try to do with john and nate is
to role model what i say and you know if
i just go back to the you know first
moment i stepped through the door of any
organization i worked for i decided to
be an out gay man in business which in
the mid 80s wasn't such a popular thing
back then no and it wasn't hard for me
you know i'm a white guy that grew up in
the san francisco bay area i worked for
you know you know levi's i had an
incredibly supportive family so i get
there was a lot of ease to that but it
was a conscious choice i made because i
believe ultimately
if you want to create followership and
you want to make sure that you're
creating an environment which is more
about love and innovation and creativity
and you know courage uh and empathy uh
and integrity you have to you have to
lead authentically and that means
bringing your whole self to work you
have to be open and check yourself
because you need to be a student of
learning every day
in order to lead a broad and diverse
group of people so that's kind of the
first point the second thing i would say
is
you have to lead
with a level of authenticity to who you
are and what your skill base is and what
your passions are and i mentioned to you
earlier i was a builder i'm a builder
you know that's if i had to use one word
to describe myself it's that so i bring
a level of
intrapreneurialism if you will into
large companies and then try to build
the bridge between the larger
organization and the more innovative
mindset that an entrepreneur like you
and they bring to bear because that's
where the formula for success is and
then root route how to get to the
outcomes that we need to deliver
together in this concept of values based
high performance i think if you're if
you're helping people be courageous uh
you know authentic creative uh to
operate with empathy listening you know
no pun intended to empathy but it's one
of my core values and then you know
obviously having integrity and how you
show up that creates a culture even if
it's demanding that isn't fear-based and
i'll tell you gary i mean it's i i get
feedback all the time for the employees
people are fearful of something with me
um but it's not they're afraid they're
fearful of disappointment yeah well
that's what that's that's the dirty
little secret for how we roll right
everything that people think they're
getting out of fear you actually get in
reverse out of love right like i i
learned this because i had such opposite
parents
right and like i just i saw it my dad
ran his company in a soviet environment
like he thought like scaring people like
you're gonna get fired or i like and i
it was just so in my face and my natural
dna was so the opposite
and you're absolutely right people like
if somebody admires you
like you don't want to disappoint them
which is a whole nother thing because
then you start having it becomes chess
right like i when i figured that part
out i was like oh [ __ ] i got to make
them understand that they can't
disappoint me in the result they can
only disappoint me in this or that you
know it's like becomes a whole
three-dimensional game of chess let me
ask you a question yeah because i've had
the luxury of owning my own business
for you know even when i was building it
for my dad i was making the calls and
occasionally he would try to get in the
way but he knew better and he let me do
my thing so i've never really
experienced
having to be this person
with having bosses
right in public company numbers like you
know
what
what is that this is a fun question for
me because i actually don't even know
where you're going to go with this
when is it hardest to uphold your
principles and your values
because the reality is one of two things
it isn't in the benefit of the company's
p l the company's bot like you know in
the macro diversity behind this of
course it's going to impact it but i'm
talking in the micro sometimes you know
i have delusional requests from my
employees
out of complete like ideology that would
like literally put our company out of
business like i literally had an
employee come in and be gary facebook
and netflix have this policy we have to
do it i'm like do you [ __ ] understand
that facebook and netflix makes more
revenue in a day than we make like do
you understand that that i can't do that
i'm like i'm happy to do it you're gonna
be looking for a job in four months that
was literally the conversation
when
or let's just call it let's be even more
authentic
you have your life and your family like
some you know they're like when is it
hot meaning sometimes a decision like if
you were to do this you will get fired
like when is it hardest
or what do you do when it's hardest
where
you know you have these ideologies but
you might have to
bend a little bit in the micro to make
the macro work like how do you go
through all of that besides pouring a
nice
glass of wine from you know premium
mondavi from tokolone to get through
that decision like
you know what else what do you do what
do you do
look one of the benefits of being in
this business is you can uh pour a great
glass of water at the end of the day
you know it's a great question what i
would say and i don't i don't want to
answer in too simplistic of a way maybe
we can just rip back and forth and
unpack it a little bit but i think you
come up against these moments where you
have to make a choice and it's a
juncture you know you've got to decide
and oftentimes i think what it is about
gary is are are you able to bend because
you can keep on the course to the
outcome that you're looking to deliver
both in terms of shareholder value
creation and
building a high performance values based
culture or is it something that's truly
going to break um break your
your brand of leadership and your
commitment to driving the right returns
in the right way and so i always come to
really simple you know principles don't
compromise your values
don't take shortcuts
don't go for a short-term victory that's
not sustainable because you should also
always be building organizations that
are going to be better for your time of
leadership and will be sustained as a
result and if you start bumping up
against those questions and you can't
answer you know with a a really firm yes
that you're you're taking the right
decision because it's it's the right
decision culturally it's the right
decision contextually it's the right
decision from a value standpoint it's
going to deliver sustained
you know profitable revenue growth for
your shareholders and especially for
your employees if you can't answer those
questions then you're making the wrong
choice and it should be really really
simple doesn't mean you shouldn't be
flexible and agile and you shouldn't
there's no straight line to an outcome
you're always taking a windy road to get
where you try to get to but
you know um when you're taking too big
of a of a curve uh and you you could
crash or break and you just need to
listen to that inner voice uh and always
follow uh you know essentially follow
your authentic
values and
authentic self
robert what uh let's go a little fun for
a little bit what uh what's what's been
the most fascinating thing
that has happened in the last five to
ten years three years
you know two years with the consumer
drinking wine in a let's just use
america
i'll go i'll go first in a little way
i'm still
because i grew up in the business my
whole life
just completely blown away that rose got
there for years right basically from the
time i was 14 to the time i when i left
kind of full true day-to-day wine
library which i always say is 2011 even
though vayner media started in 2009
so in 2011 you know i i couldn't believe
um
that
you know even at 36 years old like
my whole career and rosie still wasn't
happening and the fact that it's
happened and it's really happened
is just mind-blowing but let's go a
little bit more contemporary last two
three years
what has surprised you or been most
interesting or caught you off guard or
or your think is really cool like when i
talk about the consumer what's going on
there you can go broad obviously
consolation goes way beyond wine with
beer and spirits like what's caught your
attention of like wow i never saw that
coming or i can't believe how big this
calories gotten or it's really
interesting to see people do
yeah you know look i i mean a lot there
are a few macro level trends and you
covered rose i think i've been struck by
how
uh how strong of an uh
a sort of sensory appetite people have
for uh really fruit forward um really
yummy
cabs and red blends and that's from the
very very high end all the way through
to
an incredible um value table line
with with a similar sensory which is
slightly sweeter
so that that i think has really driven a
lot of consumption over the last um
several years but the thing that's been
most interesting to me is seeing the
market bifurcate people are demanding
incredible quality and really tasty
product um you know at the lower end
from a price segment standpoint you know
if you can economically afford to buy a
10 bottle of wine you deserve an
incredible bottle of wine and then the
high end and the high end is not only in
wine but in craft spirits but the thing
that is most disruptive right now is i
would say just all you know alternative
adult beverage um you know thinking
about ready to drink uh
pack formats and wine thinking about
ready to drink uh in spirits uh you know
even a big disruptive category to the
beer and wine category like seltzer uh
the consumer's in charge and i think
it's fun because it's demanding and
companies that are innovative and agile
uh will get there and then if you layer
on top of it you know your whole you
know career has been at least in the
wine and spirits business but i think
really broadly uh has been built this
way the consumer's in charge you know uh
direct to consumer omni channel um
social digital technology it's all about
being
with the consumer understanding because
of what you learn from them day in and
day out what they're looking for what
they like what they don't like and being
able to respond
quickly and also to surprise and delight
them in ways that they didn't expect but
it's those big macro trends that really
i think
stood the industry on its ear what about
um a different thing talk to me about
your personal robert hansen personal
social media life
tick tock instagram uh actually as a big
executive
something i'd love to hear from you how
much do you post or and or how much do
you consume content on linkedin let's
start there actually i'll take advantage
of having you here you and you know
what's going on in linkedin for you and
have you sensed over the last two three
years its rise as a content play in the
business world and your contemporaries
or other things that nature thoughts on
linkedin
yeah sure i mean look i'm i'm a huge
user of linkedin i tend to post
um around temple moments that are really
important to me personally that um you
know i've i've posted on uh
most recently on um moments where there
has been a cultural context where i
think business and society have
converged a lot about uh the social
unrest that we've been dealing with a
lot about um the issues relative to how
um you know communities of color
particularly african americans and
blacks have been treated um but those
moments are important to me because i
think i'm very committed personally and
i think the company is to diversity
equity and inclusion so i tend to use
linkedin for that purpose you never go
do you ever go fund business in linkedin
will you ever talk about like a report
you saw or because you've been in
fashion and other
areas like
i will although i will tell you to
answer your broader question and this is
maybe a little lazy you could challenge
me on this because of who you are what
you do but i tend to be a social and
digital media voyer um you know my uh my
husband has like a crazy amount of
twitter followers not gary vaynerchuk
or uh you know a man with a pretty
strong point of view and a wicked uh
talking sense of humor uh you know he's
got quite a lot of following so i use
twitter as my news source i use um you
know i use instagram um you know as my
predominant
social platform i am an observer on tick
tock i'm really fascinated by how people
behave and kind of what works and
doesn't work and the implications of
society and business but i tend to be
more of a voyeur there and i use that
predominantly and what about and what
about podcasts
um i'm a big consumer of podcasts what
are your favorite podcasts whether
they're entertainment escapism or
whether they're business like what truly
what do you actually listen to i i tend
to listen to
um
podcasts that are going to help
sort of expand my horizons personally i
am so
from a business standpoint i you know
obviously i'm talking to you i listen to
everything you put out i listen to a lot
of the influencers in my business world
um
so when i'm personally consuming
podcasts um i tend to go to my passion
points you know whether it's food
whether it's um
you know travel whether it's um sort of
just expanding my understanding of a
particular topic where i may not have
the level of skill or experience that i
want what about what about ott
what about netflix hulu hbo max what
what is robert watching these days
oh god um i am i get in so much trouble
personally for this
gracious binge watcher so i will go in
and go hard um so everything from
you know ted lasso to
you know i was one of the few people
that could stomach seeing you know the
handmaid's tale all the way through
because i love the politic you know
social political commentary about it um
you know you name it i'm uh i'm the
queen's queen's gambit oh my god the
queen's gambit i required the thing i
asked for the most because i didn't have
one for some reason or at least that's
four it was a chess board uh that's what
i got as one of my christmas presents
last time around the queen's gambit was
amazing love it so those kinds of
programs um and if i want to be um if i
want to be particularly uh
sort of just playful uh i watch hell's
kitchen a lot
i love that
he's so brilliant i love that
um
empathy right we did the transaction
together you said it quickly so i want
to bring it up
when did that
when did you know that word you know
it's funny what a word for me like
so much of what is good to me in life is
based on that word hence why i wanted to
name the wine that
incredibly interesting to look at the
google search terms and things that
nature what an under used word in our
society and now is just so in the
zeitgeist
gets thrown around and misunderstood i
think sometimes as sympathy or or you
know other things like
when did that word really resonate to
you and like and then more importantly
why do you actually think it matters so
much
in business because i i think i'd like
to think people can understand why it
should matter in life but like in
business
yeah well you know look i'll come full
circle and um and sort of you know i
know we're getting getting close to the
time you have so um you know you asked
about the mentors that i had early in my
career what was interesting to me is i
was always taught from my
mom and from my personal life empathy
matters a huge amount treat people with
respect listen to them demonstrate
empathy no matter who you are you owe
that to the people that you come come
across in life so that that was
instilled in me personally and then in
business when i first started working
with the people i mentioned earlier uh
we spent a lot of time on values and we
were asked to explore our personal
values and the five that always come up
which were aligned with every
organization except for when i made a
mistake personally in context we can
talk about that next time is my values
are clear courage um creativity
authenticity integrity empathy and it
was well before i got to know you and
was surprised by the way that you named
you know the wine brand that you
launched with john and nate it is
fundamental to who i am and um it's i
meditate every day and a lot of people i
know do um and part of my meditation is
really focusing on those values and
making sure that i'm living them every
day and reminding myself which ones have
lapsed and oftentimes empathy is the
hardest one because it requires patience
a commitment to listen and to hear other
people's stories and it's always been
important to me and i think it makes
better leaders in business robert what
what if i asked you because i'm just
trying to bring as much value as
possible i think this one can really
land for a lot of people i'm excited
about it actually
what is the most common mistakes you see
in leaders right what's so fun about
your position and i have it too
is you get to be the leader of leaders
super fun for me like i'm watching i
have some great leaders but it's fun i
get to like learn so much now that i've
got scale
i get to learn so much and you know i
used to have to when you're when you're
a smaller company you're pretty much the
leader like you know like now i'm in a
different place where i'm truly leading
leaders you you in your position have
led and continue to lead leaders what is
a very common call it 2018 to 2022
because i want to contextualize it like
a recent thing if i said to you
what what do you see the leaders what is
the mistake you see
up close and personal or like maybe
parallel or people your friends what is
the most common mistake
with an s
or just one that really stands out for
you that like people get caught up or
tripped up on
yeah
you know the one that is the most
obvious to me is leaders who set an
agenda but don't make it our collective
agenda make it their agenda
because when they do that even if the
strategy's right and they built the
right operating and financial plans they
can't get the culture and the people uh
necessary for followership and so it
falls apart so that's one the second
thing i would say is is assuming they've
created um
alignment and everyone's kind of bought
in um the the challenge i think a lot of
leaders face is their level of
impatience and they can outpace and this
is an issue i have to watch all the time
they can outpace the capability of their
team so you gotta orchestrate the
performance for the team so that people
can achieve goals and you know not burn
themselves out and have full lives and
all that stuff and the third thing i
would say and this is the toughest one i
think there's an a job out there for
everybody
and oftentimes leaders don't recognize
when they're asking somebody to do
something they either can't or don't
want to do right and i think making the
call because it's actually the most
empathetic thing to do is making a call
to help someone understand it's time to
find that next day job and i believe
that i really think there's an a job out
there for everybody it may not be the
current assignment so those are the
three things i see that people make
mistakes around and when i really get
other leaders talking and they're open
and vulnerable they would say a version
of what i just shared
robert this was super enjoyable when two
seconds i wish you nothing but health
and happiness brother thank you so much
for being on the show
same to you man great to talk to you
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon